this is a production of Cornell
University
so today we'll sort of have three
portions the first portion I will focus
on why garden based learning it's so
important followed by Rogers portion
what he'll talk a little bit about the
property of extension summer ancient
program and then Megan will sort of wrap
things up with her experience from her
internships if summer in shadow County
and then we'll have some time for
questions so at this time I'd really
like to know who is in attendance so if
you can please take a moment to sort of
share who you are and what your focus is
if you could type that into the chat box
it would be wonderful great thank you
for me that instead it in starting a
gardening program in Lewis County thank
you so much that's great so Paul we met
is shift starting out and it's very
exciting it's a very exciting stage to
be in who else is out there Jim Jen
Clancy 4-h Garden Club leader awesome
thank Jen I'd like to have just a few
more so we can see who is with us
looks like we have April a nutrition
educator in Jefferson County Farm to
School Coordinator wonderful click we
have a big diverse group today some
people starting out and some people who
have been in the field for some time
have some experience under their belt
some people focused on nutrition others
on horticulture it's just that's great
thank you it's great to know who is in
attendance so we could have a little bit
about why gardening kind of goes hand in
hand with Cooperative Extension so
Robert essential mission is to enable
people to improve their lives and
communities through partnerships and our
Comment quenelles are based learning
mission is to provide educators expiring
research space gardening resources and
professional development to support
engaging empowering and relevant
learning experiences for children youth
adults and communities we do follow the
4-h mission and empowering youth to
reach their full potential
working and learning and partnership
with caring adults you can see that
these missions really go hand in hand
and we really lean on each other it's a
great partnership so in my portion um
Siana speaking I will really like to lay
down some sort of research base findings
on white barn based learning is so
important so before I start I'd like to
sort of see why do you think this work
is important you could just take a
moment to share why you believe garden
based learning is meaningful and in your
work or your personal life you can type
that into the chat box it would be great
awesome Thank You Colleen people learn
more when doing hands-on work and I'm
we're willing to come to learn to
appreciate and appreciate our
environment hopefully we can serve it so
true Megan any people anytime people can
get out into nature and get hands-on
experience they appreciate more how
they're coming back
can I see people back to their food
source from Paulina Thank You Jen says
it encourages healthy eating and teaches
where food comes from these are all
wonderful points April that kids learn
best by doing non-traditional learners
to grasp concepts that may struggle with
from a textbook
you can teach anything from growing and
preparing food I agree April thank you
awesome thank you everybody so really
our hope for the future generation is
that they respect and care for the
natural world I think we can all agree
upon that but the reality is that there
is a extreme disconnect with nature in
this future generation children are
increasingly disconnected from nature
due to over structured schedule lots of
green space parental fear and the
prevalence of electronic and if children
are losing their connection with nature
who will care enough about wildlife and
open spaces to advocate in 10 or 20
years if children don't have direct
intimate experiences with nature they
will not care if it goes away they need
good times in the outdoors to realize
how wonderful it is config is a must eat
fresh berries to appreciate the hard
work of these this bonding time with
nature should start early and continue
your life what we're experiencing in
nature deficit disorder sort of coined
by Richard foo it's real it's happening
I actually found this yesterday from the
big book of nature activities a
year-round guide to after living and it
just sort of seeks some really
interesting figures for us to look at so
2,500 is the number of advertising
messages a child encounters in one day
that is crazy 2738 is the number of
hours the average North American child
sits in front of a glowing screen for a
year
Wow 183 the number of hours a child
spend outdoors and unstructured play per
year which that figure which swaps with
the one above it and 300 is the
percentage that obesity has increased
over the past 20 years for children aged
6 to 11
vanishing dream is also the number of
corporate logos the average child can
identify but only 10 is the number of
native plants and animals that the
average child can identify I feel like
these figures you know I just
appropriate and sort of relative to
children but also our society as a whole
so our job is to really bring that
connection back to nature so our hope so
our children will be physically active
and healthy this little girl is so cute
on her party bike but the reality
something much different half of
American kids you're not used to
physical activity guidelines they get 46
hours of video games or television
display a day that means there's less
time for them to be outside exploring
playing getting muddy and dirty finding
treating falling out of them all those
really important sort of pieces
childhood and you feel the childhood is
a critical time to establish healthy
lifestyle habits another hope is that
our children will be nutritionally
healthy and food secure which means they
can access and consume safe affordable
culturally appropriate nutrients of food
the reality is that they're
nutritionally deficient factors include
for access lack of affordability
convenience and habits menu with youth
living food deserts and have limited
access to healthy foods practically 18%
of Americans aged two to nine years are
obese and obesity is the number one
health concern among parents in the
United States that has two drugs and
smoking that's crazy
our hope is that our children will have
the education that they need to feel
empowered to establish leadership and
confidence this
important foundational time to establish
these things into trying to sing to ask
questions the factual is kind of fall
into a fit or fail all system education
has become streamlined teaching has
become to hit the standards in the
standardized test snap for the
individual and really memorization has
taken over mastery
there's less time for critical thinking
creativity and imagination education has
become rigid and strict I can definitely
echo this portion where I felt like you
know when I was at school it was more
about jumping through hoops and
memorizing things for an egg rather than
really using my critical thinking skills
so to fuel the future of kids we have to
think about there is child and tired
lifestyle
I hope there wasn't too much doom and
gloom for you but it's very important to
share that this information it's
critical at this point time and society
and now to the stack stuff the gardens
are a wonderful gateway to learning and
discovery for the whole child look at
that garden I wish I was there right now
so beautiful so let's talk about some of
the positive effects of gardening so
children you garden
are more comfortable with outdoors have
increased awareness and appreciation
from the natural world have ownership
responsibility they've become
environmental stewards they that
important sense of wonder and desire to
ask questions you know there are been
studies that show that the love of
gardening is not so much about gardening
but about making decisions having the
freedom to make your own decisions is
incredibly powerful and this can happen
in the garden
I love this John Burroughs quote that
knowledge without love will not stick
but if love comes first the knowledge to
sure follow we need to connect kids back
that love nature
children who Gardens also have improve
nutrition and self-awareness healthy
eating can help prevent or delay chronic
conditions and studies have shown that
kids implanted edik or at least try it
these healthy food choices start during
childhood and will continue through
adulthood early exposure is key they've
also done studies that children's
Gardens have higher learning
achievements they have higher test
scores especially in science and math
they also discover unique personal
strengths and still more I can and I
belong did learn to make decisions and
problem-solve they gain greater
self-esteem they learn interpersonal
skills teamwork they're more likely to
build stronger relationships with others
and they're more engaged in their
community which i think is really
important and wonderful gardening is
schools to increase this achievement
scores increases parental involvement
community involvement really supplements
that hands-on learning that might not be
already in the school system enhances
storytelling written expression reading
and comprehension and spelling just
overall it's wonderful in gardening I
provide you know that type of learning
that's more hands-on and experiential so
there really is something for everyone
and the benefits of gardening aren't
just for you they're for all ages it
enhances mental health helps reduce
stress lowers your blood pressure so
ease muscle tension and helps combat
obesity I know that when I've had a hard
day at work or some around fat when I
get home once I start reading improving
and caring for my plants I feel a whole
lot better
she's therapeutic here's a quote from a
child that I think just about sums
everything up gardening makes me happy
it makes me proud of me Reggie makes me
feel healthy
I can garden with family and friends I
love it so as you can see in our garden
we are growing way more efficient plants
this work is important this work is real
we are cultivating passion and
empowerment with the next generation we
are having both youth and adults for
some more to become environmental
stewards and to care for their natural
world
we're inspiring youth and adults to make
healthier choices and we help their
lives well I hope that sort of gave you
a good foundation of why garden based
learning is so powerful and especially
critical at this moment of time now I'd
like to turn it over to Roger all right
Thank You Fiona let's transfer over and
here to make sure we can I can work
these slides for you all and good
morning thank you for being here today
my perspective here is a little bit from
quatro Extension educator and how we
have this is our second year with a
College of Ag and life sciences in turn
so we've gone through the program now I
think we applied for years and we've won
an intern for two years so wonder Sharon
I apologize my first slides are going to
be a little bit on the
ringg wordy side but it's how we wrote
for our intern because I thought it was
more important for me to share with you
the wording that we use because I
believe that's important on how you're
developing your program to make it fit
of course for yourself but also how that
it works for Cornell to be able to
provide one of these interns which is
just been a blessing having Megan this
year in Brittany last year if anybody
sat through Brittany's presentation last
year these are both great youth and
really benefited our program beyond what
I can put on these slides so let me go
to my first slide here and I apologize
again it's gonna be a little wordy but
maybe you can use this in when you're
writing so the project summary and
intended outcomes that we identify were
the interesting gardening is growing
throughout New York State and CCE
continues to explore the most innovative
avenues for which to educate and inspire
citizens demonstration gardens have
proven to be an important arena for a
number of significant learning
opportunities Schuyler CCE has
identified the need for a continued a
strengthened approach to a local
demonstration garden as a way to help
hundreds of local residents learn more
about horticulture and area educators
learn from our success so it's also
about sharing know and everything so
sorry oh that's alright that's alright
Thank You Fiona so an efficient I'll
just explain a little bit on four
different things there where I go on the
reading this slide is so there's are so
much strawberries that we have I'm a
specialty collector is we got some
strawberries donated and that's our
things growing in our garden Chicago
Hardy so we do some weird things and we
do a lot of common things and Cornell
vegetable trials things like that so we
try to mix a lot of different things in
for the intern experience so far two of
the project summary and intended
outcomes here on this slide this garden
based learning in turn will help Skylar
CC build upon the success of last
summer's internship to further develop
utilize and maximize the educational
benefit
the attractive spacious teaching garden
which lies adjacent to the Sisi office
complex and was established five years
ago as an outdoor classroom the initial
progress of our garden was a grant
Health Department of Health grant from
our local community we adopted the
grants who sit on the proposal for our
garden and got us established which I'll
show you some slides here later so we're
trying to keep this teaching garden idea
we call a teaching garden AARC when they
come to visit they call it the learning
part because of what they get out of
working with us and the community
partnerships that we've developed so
next i want to spoil us and show us a
little bit of winter here because i know
we're so excited about getting through
summer this is I think this year's gonna
be the best time in my garden as a feel
that nice snow out there so continuing
on the summary and intended outcomes
here the summer interns will begin with
an overview of important initiatives
such as sustainability diversity and
inclusion as well as practical guidance
related to stakeholder needs assessment
and successful program development
processes house develop and deliver a
season long curriculum with input from
the leadership share the results of the
approach through diverse documentation
which will include a web-based success
story to be distributed for CCE news in
the Cornell garden based learning blog
and potentially host a regional workshop
to share with other CC educators are
learning from the trajectory of a
two-year internship experience of a
growing audience base so this is that
part there where the regional workshops
to share with you other educators what
we have learned and that's my goal here
today and we'll have plenty of time for
questions at the end because we want you
to take this we feel really blessed that
we were awarded in turn two years in a
row and we've made so many strides with
our garden and due to that in turn of
working with audiences that in the past
I
not a full-time horticulture educator so
how we could pull this off with this
apart time and now luckily this year but
I'm back full time has worked to our
benefit
so next ok the students role okay so the
brief descriptions of student interns
role and responsibilities so under the
supervision of the collaborators listed
above that would have been in our and
our rating for our intern we will
participate in a preparation session
which I think Fiona and Marsha worked
with Meghan to get her started and give
her a little background about garden
based learning developed and delivered
targeted educational programs for both
youth and adult audiences we work with
Head Start isn't our building a RC as a
group home nearby they've come out twice
we would like to come out three times a
week wet is in our building on Fridays
pins is youth at risk program in our
building and we worked with those which
there's a lot of boys that one evening
they were a lot of fun and 4-h at the
teaching garden with guidance and
attentively adapting for now garden
based learning curricula create and hand
and lead activities that support the
maintenance of the garden observe how
volunteers are developed supervised and
rewarded and work with educators to
implement to volunteer trainings and
gain experiences monitor for pests
collect data and variety trials we're
always getting plants coming is the most
recent ones I could pick up where the
Rutgers cranberry trials that we did we
did straw bail trials you know variety
trials so we're always getting some
things from Cornell strawberries and so
on like that and lastly their report and
share the results regionally and
statewide to educate and inspire others
Megan is part of this is going to be the
most beneficial to all of you all the
projects hopefully that least give
successfully through this year what
qualifications were needed so in writing
for the intern we had to identify those
so the candidate will need to need
excellent written and oral communication
skills a genuine desire and documented
interested working with people is
necessary she or he should be in tendons
of detail and to possess a general
knowledge of and enthusiasm for
gardening and home food production and
lastly there a desire to work with a
variety of audiences and an interest in
the ability to perform physical working
after our conditions all these are
really crucial and I'm just going to
step back through these one more time
written oral skills for Megan has been
her blog and her ability to write
articles for us that is just an
exceptional working with people you're
working with garden volunteers one
minute you're working with an audience
of maybe youth at risk the next moment
so she was put in various programs so
that she'll talk more of on an
enthusiasm for gardening I think
whenever I interviewed Megan she had
worked for a CSA last year and it really
showed even though Megan that she'll
tell you more of it she's from a animal
science background really had a love of
plants along with that and that was
necessary for this to work out really
well
and that last one they were working with
a variety of audiences and interests
physical work in outdoor conditions this
year working outside in the garden if
you didn't like a little bit of heat it
would not have worked at all so Megan
has a keen ability to be able to work in
the heat morbid and then Riley I would
be been able to so it was extraordinary
to find the youth that really tolerated
alright so next benefits and skills that
we could hopefully then provide our
intern so we said the increased
knowledge of CC successful program
developed
process we bring that to the table basic
gardening and local group production
experience volunteer development written
oral expression intern will gain
significant experience and facilitating
learning experiences both adult and
youth audiences in an outdoor classroom
environment through the co leadership of
numerous classes and activities so we
just try to develop a listing of what
we're giving back we take a lot from an
intern probably in any of the programs
but what are we giving them back but
they can take with them beyond her
experience here and for Megan I think I
signed her farewell card with if you
grow others you grow yourself and so
that sort of follows the Fiona's little
tagline there that we do more with this
grow plants the audience's that we reach
really have this needs of learn
gardening and it's so neat to see an
intern work with those audiences and
hopefully we provided that opportunity
so here is my welcome slide before I go
for a little bit about our garden on
there but here's a little where I wanted
to get you to chat a little bit is what
type of Gardens do you want to work with
or are already working with back home
ideas would be you know do you have a
teaching garden or learning garden like
ours are you more working in a community
garden a school garden a food plot I
know somebody answered a little bit with
Fiona but just drive me down like what
audiences or what type of garden are you
planning back home we're already have
but you're utilizing so give you a
minute here before I move on okay we
work with you elderly in workshops but
do not have a designated area or garden
this is our next wish to have in our
program thank you colleague Katie I'm
hoping to get some demonstration gardens
going in Orleans County and you started
with two small raised bed one dedicated
to herbs and the other to pollinator
native plants Thank You Katie well keep
them
in everybody I'm going to move on a
little bit to the garden here here's our
little welcome board this is the center
of a teaching platform that we have that
we developed in our garden which you can
see some benches sort of there and
there's eight holes that are for grapes
whoops I got April we were hoping to
help our local school of lament gardens
and garden education in addition to
local procurement Thank You April so
this little teaching platform you a
little better picture up so as I said a
couple years ago Department of Health
and Schuyler County had this grant why
you have connections in your community
and they contacted us that nobody had
applied for this grant that's like not
heard of anymore that's why people
fighting over grants so they said Roger
we know you're new but we've heard you
want to establish a garden this was a
big grass plot out on the road they said
we can help you do that if you write for
this grant maybe you are pretty much the
only person so far so I wrote for this
grant and this was not to be taken
lightly this was $7,500 I think just
artists we use it for infrastructure we
be we built this teaching platform and
you'll see Ann Arbor but we put over top
of some picnic tables that were out the
middle of nowhere nobody would come out
and sit because the three picnic tables
were in the baking Sun and we also put a
little Arbor for entrance and you'll see
this pack travel that's around here this
is a wheelchair accessible and also the
raised beds were made for wheelchair
height we did all that with the initial
I would say 95% of the plants were all I
wrote different companies and they were
all more annoying the donate plant so we
have paid for very little of the plants
and I feel blessed at this point might I
have a little nursery at home but I've
been able to donate some plants this
year to help the garden along because
it's really my passion so I did a
donated some fruiting plants this year
so we just keep adding as we go so
here is I think the first couple weeks
after it was developed with the raise
planners the teaching platform in the
middle which is sort of a old English
style amphitheater the big Arbor down at
the end we beefed out because we put
party Kiwi on top of those and off to
the right of the picture you can't see
would have been our wheelchair entrance
off of the main walkway coming in
because we wanted to make sure this
garden was developed for all folks who
to be able to participate in our
programs this was probably now about few
years back megohm was laughing at me she
said if you took this picture today you
couldn't see for any of this because
that big quince in the foreground and as
elderberries that fried double that size
the grapevines have taken over that are
versus you feel like you're in an
enclosure now that they have grown so
the garden has really taken off and this
is all just volunteer because I said I
was only part-time as of last year so
bomb tears our first three master
gardeners came out of Compton County
last year so we didn't even have a
Master Gardener program so again make it
out to the fetcher I caught her right
when the bug bitter but this is some of
our like master gardeners our garden
volunteers our nutrition staff and Megan
working on a ladybug adoption night
where we department in biology was
donating for that donating but had bred
the nines by the ladybugs and we had a
adopt them and release them in our
garden night so you know this is a good
diversity because it is four different
groups together working in the garden at
one time this is something and I said I
won't belabor these because Megan is
going to show you this is a lot of her
work this is her ladybug adoption flier
we made the interns we teach them and
then we make him do everything that we
would do crate flyers book rooms
help with the speakers
with the ladybugs she went along we
picked them up up at Cornell it was a
cool experience videotaping the ladybugs
larvae so this was just one of her
pliers that she created she'll more
about that later
she did this trifold which was just a
real creative all about ladybugs for
kids we gave that out the night that
that folks came in and adopted and I
think we had as many adults as kids
adopt ladybugs that night it was really
just a cool educational with that in the
garden okay
community groups oh we might we talked
about a RC this is the A or C group it
was out in the garden Pimm's diversion
is you fat risk we all know wex
headstart programs that are building
office for the aging Xin our building
Department of Social Services has a work
crew that we have worked with and they
have expressed like how great it is to
learn gardening skills when they're
already teaching their participants
work-related skills so they really
appreciate coming out to our garden and
this is just a little history behind
this slide is that both from AARC has
gone to a rain barrel building workshop
somewhere else not in our garden they
love our garden so much you'll see the
water is light there they donated their
barrel to our garden so it's really
incredible that they thought about us
and we love working with them and Negin
will talk more about that of course on
our previous slide megan has worked on
her internship vlog it is amazing she'll
talk more about there please go on in
here I'm not nearly that creative of
putting videos into my blog I'm lucky I
could just type a simple letter to you
guys so so these you bring other skills
that I feel bad that I don't know better
our plants I need is our claim the same
in our garden Megan was thrown right
into any new varieties you'll see some
were from my farm donated we tried to
get the newest plant material that we
see that is available that folks want to
learn these are some bush cherries from
the University of New Hampshire the
meter program I believe so when we bring
that in it automatically gets a sign put
on it because the garden is 24/7 open
codes come there to learn they're
welcome to taste test it is just of
course the deer visit as much as people
knew we're working on that but so the
signage is the most important thing so
Meghan got to do a lot of signs a lot of
research on the varieties it's a lot of
work researching where they came from
giving credit designing the science at
along along with our signage is our
nutrition I believe in Meghan we'll
probably talk more about that there's 12
sort of like those for sure holder that
you would get for an open house at home
that's for sale they're clear with a pot
lid because open space all around our
garden and we try to put that either
with timely planting information or here
some of our nutrition education one side
is our description educator Lisa's
archive issues that camp from the summer
we have no other nutrition staff so
without an intern I would not be able to
look up recipes and get that out for the
garden I just would not have time for
that so so she was able to get timely
recipes out there when crops were coming
ready obviously here kale and rhubarb
we're in season in the garden so she
kept up with that and we when we did
some monitoring and make it a lot more
about like how many did we put out there
how many were taken you know things like
that we did some some record-keeping
also this is a Master Gardener program
is back after a long hiatus in Schuyler
County so she was tasked to get a Master
Gardener we want you kind of deal
we went through ideas of like Uncle Sam
you know or or we had a Batman theme
around me a superhero be a Master
Gardener in Schuyler County
so who work long as hard on developing
because our master gardeners go out to
local farmers markets and supplement
like how do we find past present and
future master gardeners or a program so
we develop this out there onto the
health of my particular program summer
RAC this is Meghan she's not worried
about this she went out with our youth
educator Paula so this is a 4-h event
Austin - a summer recreation program and
Odessa New York and work with youth as
many ages like I sound like a steal
Megan's thunder but just want to share
that we do outside of n to get our
intern out of the garden so she's not
there sweating every day how can we get
her out then utilize her and I heard she
did a wonderful turtle project that
she'll talk to you about more little
publisher we work hard as I started this
but we keep up with this little drawing
every time you put new plants and they
get updated on here and when we had some
a permaculture tour go from last year
they were really impressed that garden
map existed they go to a lot of eat
gardens but nobody really puts where the
plants are for you to find them you just
sort of randomly come across them so the
garden map was really a great thing for
folks who visit us so I think Megan it's
your turn so thank you everybody I'll
take questions at the end
Hey hopefully you guys can hear me okay
as Roger and Fiona said my name is Megan
I was the Schuyler County summer intern
and I'm just here to talk about my
experiences with the program what my big
takeaways are and why
other Extension programs like what some
of you guys work for my consider wanting
an intern I'm going into this job I
really didn't know didn't know what to
expect my majors animal sciences Roger
says I had pretty limited experience
with horticulture but I work on a farm
expedia subjects I've interested just
with the attention off the pet store for
me initially my job just entails fixing
up the garden reading mulching making
new signs and facilitating the mini
bi-weekly workshops with ARC that Roger
mentioned before and any other tweeny
group and helping out with various
projects around the office but don't
think so much more than that
and I'll break endowment into a few
categories because it ended up extending
wavy are we've got initial scope so
first the garden I'm mostly the entire
plot I forgot a ton of weeds and this is
just kind of a general labor of it it
all took a lot longer than I thought
mulching it and just taking down all the
old science items and besides I took
about lots of before and after pictures
you can kind of see the progress that
there was throughout the summer I
planted to the ton new seeds we acquired
a big donation about half way through
the summer that had tons of like
tomatoes peppers cucumbers and
cantaloupe plants as Roger said he
donated several of its own plants
including a goji berry bush a couple of
new blueberry varieties and three plus
cherries that I planted with members of
our updated of all the garden signs made
new ones and put together some healthy
garden relevant recipes that we put in
the garden flyer holders for pasture by
the cake no sorry also Jen and I'm so
happy with how the garden looks now
obviously I could continue to work on it
forever because there's always something
to do but I think it's taught me most of
what it can for the meantime which is
valuable enough I'll go back to this
secondly working with community groups
each Tuesday and Thursday each Tuesday
and Thursday one to three members of arc
would come and their caretaker and I
would facilitate a garden activity with
them and sometimes it would be something
simple like we just plant seeds or read
water or Rapide and then sometimes I
would prepare a more intensive activity
beforehand like we made turtle sprouts
which is the picture right in the middle
and it's sort of like a very busy at
home chia pet and I did that was a
summer rec program and I did it with arc
and I think both of them really liked
the activity and benefited from it we
extended the opportunity to work with
wick and pinch diversion but never heard
back from wick we had one evening where
we worked with tens diversion about
hookers with maybe 15 boys and they were
great they were really into the garden
and even though we were doing more doing
anything necessarily exciting I think
they really enjoyed it and then finally
I worked alongside Paula the picture to
the far right during the summer rent
program where her and I have put
together our long activities for the
odessa's central school that took place
each Tuesday for a month and the
activities were all cards based and the
kids ranged from kindergarten to sixth
graders and the activities would get
like a little harder with each age group
but I'll discuss more of that in a
moment and then finally working on stuff
in office made a ton of science all for
the garden a lot of them was just
updating older signs and then sometimes
I made new signs for dinner plans that
we had I had a bigger hand in like
advertising and marketing and I expected
so like the ladybug adoption for
instance put together several Flyers the
trifold poster that you see in this
slide as well as like a brochure and
along the way I learned a ton about
ladybug akka talk your ear off about it
before
an hour not that anyone said but this
was just an example of Judy's that I
ended up having that I didn't
necessarily expect but I'm I'm happy
that I was able to contribute so now
we'll talk about the takeaways I'm going
to go back I realized the power of
garden can have it provides an
affordable way to grow fresh produce I I
discovered just an absolute passion for
it I love horticulture now and I'm
considering pursuing that further but as
you can see the garden really evolved
over time it it has all the signs which
like marked different areas of the
garden now fully mulched and we did the
headstart garden looks absolutely
amazing although that's a good part
Karen one of our master gardeners
planted a cayenne pepper bed two of
those from the donation that I received
from a woman who worked for arc Roger
nine babies netted raised beds so that
the deer can get to them dear where is
the absolute bane of our existence at
the tire summer they ate everything but
this like netted bed was it's producing
tons of tomatoes because the deer
weren't able to get to it as you can see
everything just it like looks a lot more
put together but my price joists for the
summer for sure
and so the big takeaways a gardening is
it's so much more than just plant it and
I kind of thought this is cheesy going
into this but like it's absolutely true
a garden is helpful in so many different
ways that we wouldn't even expect
obviously it produces a lot of food it
provides an affordable way to grow your
own fresh produce which is really a
valuable tool especially for like lower
incomes and
- sometimes can't afford all the fresh
produce that they need for the final
installment of the summer rec program we
made garden salsa where we use
ingredients either found in the garden
or we have to supplement some from the
grocery store because we didn't have
enough for the entire group of kids but
getting till I see the kids like like
actually working with like the tomatoes
and onions and peppers that we had grown
ourselves was exciting it's like they
can do that too they can grow it and
then they can make a delicious snack out
of everything that they harvest from
there it provides a sort of education
working in the garden just personally
has taught me so much this summer I've
learned a ton about plan insects insect
life but I probably never would have
gotten as great of detail about if I
just taken a course I believe anyone who
has the garden even if it's just for
like leisure or pleasure would
inevitably learn so much over time
lovely I have Roger - thanks for sharing
his experience of knowledge about plants
with me which in turn I tried my best to
pass on to either the children or the
arc members that I worked with over the
summer just learning the basics about
soil health and health times grow what
was there pests like etc those are
things that will stick with you and be
useful like your entire life just with
the kids we would of course do garden
related activities which were fun like
the turtle sprouts or we played bug
bingo but I think from each of those
activities there is a take away where
the kids because remember something like
oh this insect is especially bad on this
plant like in the future if they're just
out in nature and they see that bug like
I hope that they'll remember the things
that we taught them even if it's totally
small like fiona was saying earlier
gardening is incredibly therapeutic I've
been told several times that members of
ours who came to the garden frequently
for the workshops that I did with them
really benefited from the experience and
I could even see it week to week like a
few of the members too
continually came back there at the
summer would come and they'd be so
excited to see me they like come out of
the car and be like what we didn't say
what have you got planted and it was
really exciting to see like that weekly
progression that they were actually
thrilled to keep coming back and by the
end of the summer some of the members
were like so excited that when I told
them that I was leaving they actually
got really sad and I'm sad that I can't
continue working with them just because
it was such a beneficial experience
personally I would just use the garden
is an escape at a lot of my mind or
wasn't having a good day and like he
owned a said just an hour work so on the
guard and I would feel infinitely better
as far as self fulfillment if I mean
guarding is work if fun and it's
relaxing was definitely work you'll weed
and your lawn mulch and you'll sweat
you'll get incredibly discouraged when
things that you plant die or what a deer
something that just like put in the
ground but the gratification that comes
with seeing like the first tomato that
you planted ripen or
the sprouts coming out that you planted
it's unbeatable and it is really
fulfilling and I tried to point out this
progress to especially the ours members
I worked with because we planted a lot
of seeds so each week they came back I
would take them back to where we send us
you'd be like look it's just
you see planted and now they're stressed
and they're coming up and what they
don't do flowers and the fact that they
can have even just that small amount of
ownership over the garden and its
success is a great accomplishment and
finally Gardens can be and at least in
my experience this summers a perfect
platforms for forming connections both
with nature and other people there's
something so essential with connecting
with plants and there are a lot of
people loose nowadays like fiona was
talking about you called me an
appreciation for the earth and how we as
people work with it and communicate with
it and that's really invaluable and I
also truly believe that everyone can
enjoy a garden even if they're not
someone who to kick you
really likes being outside like everyone
can find something about it that they
enjoy and a number of people I met and
befriended in the garden is truly
uncountable like just people who walk by
the garden or walk through it I will
talk to them for 10-15 minutes and and
to see that like they really appreciated
the beauty of the garden so whether my
role was as a facilitator or teacher
like with our core the kids are just
like a helping hand like with my
co-workers and the master gardeners I
can honestly say I won't forget the
people I've connected with this summer
and I hope that they think of the garden
and finally as I do so to kind of close
up and over sort of running out of time
here but why I have an intern for all of
you people listening if you're
considering having an intern or applying
for an intern in the future I'd like to
just share my own experience so that you
can know that it really can make a
difference both to the intern and to
your program regardless oh sorry
an intern can be a new perspective I was
lucky in that Roger gave me a lot of
freedoms to attend to the garden and
plant activities with Park as I saw fit
and as a result a lot of new ideas of
all effects like create a new fence in
the garden and signs dividing it into
easy-to-follow sections like the
butterfly garden raspberry patch but I
had minimal prior experience with
gardening and working with community
groups so I learned as I went and
hopefully I was able to look at
everything from a fresh point of view
also a intern can be a helping hand and
tons of tons of ways as I said earlier I
ended up having a lot more duties than
helping out with things that I didn't
expect which is great because I helped
out Roger Kathy Paula that people I work
with all in a number of different
projects while still routinely working
in the garden and as a result got so
much accomplished and really gained tons
of new skills and it's like different
areas that I didn't expect over the
course of summer and finally like having
an intern
changing students lives I was really
indecisive about what I wanted
coming into this summer which is
something clearly why I'm an animal
science major in an internship pretty
unrelated to animals but working with
the incredible people in the Extension
Office and connecting with so many
community members I began to get a
better idea of what I love to do of
course and fillin sure about a lot but
just this summer has convinced me that
at least pursue a minor in horticulture
because I wouldn't trade the experiences
I had for anything and while the summer
was hard I don't regret a single part of
it and I loved it so thank you to
everyone I work with Rodger Fiona and I
think now we're going to ask some
questions try to engage you guys thank
you so much and I wanted this chime in
she didn't highlight that one picture
but the linee bug cupcakes were amazing
highlight of ladybug adopts at night so
our nutrition staff kudos all right well
thank you so much for listening so
patiently for a few minutes so now's
your time to sort of ask any questions
that you might or yeah we really like
this next week we walked off in a half
hour or so so there's money time to you
know how to levy discretion don't be shy
so you can either type your question
into the chat box or you can raise your
hand and they can come unmute you
hi Katie tell them
so Katie I think I can answer that when
how did you protect your science and the
elements out in the garden they really
only our color isn't stay fast yet we're
trying to figure that out so the
pictures of legs of the apples and so on
did not last too long but the black ink
on a card stock has lasted this pretty
much for a year do we replace them again
but the color phase really fast that we
have not been able to solve that when
they're yet so if anybody ever has a
good color fast printer ink or something
we're trying to work on that but the
black on the cardstock has lasted mine
great looks like you have another
question from Paulina where you get
lunch of your funding from sort of as
stated in the presentation all the
plants were donated so that is a hundred
percent or ninety five percent we had a
little pot of money I think three
hundred dollars each year was set aside
from proper extension for the garden in
our budget so we purchased tools and
knickknacks and things like that with a
$300 but like I said everything that was
built came from the initial Department
of Health grant was all the major
construction we really never did any
more construction after that one I wish
we had but we never finished our one
walkway I see we're back where we go and
I mean said oh hang on do you plan on
only having college interns or do you
plan on using high school a attorneys um
we'd like to have additional interns I
know we were really blessed to get two
years for the cows program probably be
lucky to ever get a third year because I
heard two years was pretty pretty
incredible we're always looking for
interns it's hard sometimes because we
are out
for like Megan she had to drive out each
day for from Ithaca where she lived
Britney last year lived a bokken plan
that was really close so maybe a high
school one or a high school program that
actually has some youth we could also
take a look at Elmira College and some
local colleges where some youth might
have to do a little bit of intern before
they graduate as it will happen to do a
lot of exploring over this winter of
some other options and follow up from
coming and funding our interns are not
available in the future how will the
garden will be sustained or kept alive
okay so colleagues question their
interns are going to be a question mark
so we know we have three master
gardeners that completed the program of
the Tompkins with Pat we plan on sending
a couple more folks that are interested
in the Master Gardener program and
they've been really reliable with
helping our garden Debbie who is one of
our master gardeners actually has to
take a bus because she cannot drive
twice a week she comes almost all year
long she is really dedicated so we have
passionate people also a lot of our
volunteers that are master gardeners
just love the community engagement in
the gardens because it is very vocal and
they like to just come out there just
help out and I put a call out for help
like the weeds are getting a little big
how can we get a weeding party together
as they show up it's just incredible the
interest level we have so I don't
believe it interns are going to be
things like I said before two years was
pretty lucky
but maybe books developed other ideas I
am also full-time now so being able to
help out especially Megan leaves I'll be
doing the arsc
tourist place a week and stuff so she's
made a good base for us to keep it
running for the rest of all and then we
had the winner to to regroup and go from
there another time question where the
signs laminated in house are sent out to
a printing company
um that was actually a project for Megan
G Lana is actually she blew off one of
our lamb
so we know the amount of laminating we
did whether we bring what up so so we do
a lot of laminating on the science so
she did everything from developing some
brand new ones to printing out the old
ones to laminating them and then we had
this old little system where we have a
try to soil water department puts in
fencing and they split a bunch of
pressure-treated poles when they're
pounding they donate those to us and we
cut them into little angled sign holders
that sit out in the garden I said is it
a close-up one for you so we put a
little dab a silicon behind where the
staple is going to be the sign goes on
and then a staple goes through and then
a dab of silicone on the outside of
staples so water doesn't ruin our signs
and then like I said we're really pretty
good except for color making one full
season before we have to replace them
back out there and we just consider that
part of our budget for the garden
putting the science out there because
that is our silent salesperson and we
were selling something but it is one of
those votes they're one of those
projects where we see folks in the
garden when I'm leaving at night
sometimes at nine o'clock there might be
a family out there taking some fresh
raspberries and reading the site and
then it's same in the morning at those
joggers they'll stop and look at what's
that quince tree I've never seen
something like that so people always and
we just had Meghan's farewell meal out
the garden yesterday and when we went to
come in I had three questions in a row
of folks who stopped because somebody
was in the garden and they asked the
gardening related question that they may
not have come in our building for
because you come through security and
it's just a little spooky to some folks
to have to come through sheriff's and
stuff so when you're out in the garden
you get a bike Megan said you get
approached by tons of community members
asking what this is how do I solve this
you know I have trees dying from the
drought how do I want them properly so
it's that connection when you're out
there it's
good for that awesome thank you I have a
question for both Roger and Megan Bell
so for everyone else than pretending
this everyone that have sort of look at
top garden based learning resource or
top activity that they find works really
well um it could be anything
yes so pretty share um I mentioned it a
few times
and this is the turtle sprout activity
but it's a activity I pulled from
Cornell's garden based learning website
and it meant for sweet ages like
kindergarten - maybe like fifth grade or
something but it kind of has all the
essentials of gardening packed into one
and it's fun like kids get to like draw
their own turtle and then you feel
justice talking with some grass feed
with art I believe we we did still
instead but so you just put some sort of
like scripta seed in the bottom that's
small enough where it'll come up through
the pantyhose and then soil on top and
tie it off you just water it every other
day it's very simple and then it starts
growing and unfortunately I wasn't able
to see the kids that I did this activity
with a second time like a week later
because I would have loved to ask them
if they like kept up with it if it
actually started sprouting but I think
that's just like a fun activity really
affordable and like we did it we did it
in mass amounts we have like 30 kids
plus I did several more the next today
with art and it was very cheap and fun
and tossing a decent amount about
gardening in a short amount of time
yeah I'll chime in with another one
along those same lines of being very
affordable and very easy and sort of
next to material intensive and this one
that you can call them seed bombs or
skeet balls or anything really so you
pretty much just take a large chunk of
clay in each person it's a small piece
of it they flatten it out and in the
middle of sort of the clay paddy you
some soil and some seeds they can be
wild flower seeds they can be really any
type of seeds I've done mint with basil
before and then you smash it all into a
ball and it's just so easy the kids love
the tactile kind of fun getting dirty
part of it but their altercation scenes
home with them to plant then our plant
at a later date so that's another really
easy one that you can set up you know if
you didn't know you had some coming oh
wait you know it's juicy balls are
really easier setup and I thought we
scroll down might have somebody after
Katie
maybe I'll get let's hear somebody else
about gravel put our pathways you think
landscape fabric instead you feel gravel
was better so our walkways have fabric
underneath so that is like part of the
answer and then a little bit chunkier
stone and then a really fine I think
they call it some dust from our
landscaper and when that pax
it is hard as cement which is a little
loose on top so wheelchairs strollers
human walkers go really really well
because of how it packs so but it is all
three levels in there so the fabric is
below the Kiwis for coming up I'm going
to get a little transitional weeds at
the edge but try to come in with a pool
really easy out of that it's probably a
good two inches thick of that stone dust
and that would put in from our
landscaper and like I said if I could
ever afford to do the other half of the
garden so there's an exit back out on
the other end we would continue with
that stone dust because it works so well
for wheelchairs on there and Pauline
expressions you have control worksheets
for that activity measure that is
directed towards the turtles cross or
the sea balls but another turtles frogs
are on the coral garden based learning
website if you go to lessons and
activities they should be in there and
there are downloadable PDFs and
you'll find a whole lot of other great
activities too so if everyone's checking
out and yes we will be posting the
slides the whole webinar has been
recorded thankfully I remember it was
really easy project once I am able to
download the webinar I should transfer
it to a different format I will then
upload it to YouTube so if you have any
questions I'm not able to find it in the
next few days you can always email me my
email address is out there and Fiona I
want to share if you ever some of you
probably have the old project wet
curriculum in there is the water cycle
game it is a little bit more because I
had to build it and laminate the dice
that you roll but the little beads that
the kids get and through the water cycle
game and then they share that bracelet
at the end with their friends and they
can see they got five of the dark blue
in a row because they were stuck in the
ocean it's where the water droplet
travels so sometimes like if it's like
coming out of an animal as you're in
three years only like one time that
you're there but sometimes you may be it
stuck in the cloud or in the ocean
multiple times and you may get seven
beads in a row because you don't leave
that station so they really grasp the
understanding of where that water
droplet and all that makes sense that it
wouldn't be there very long verses yeah
I'd be stuck as a water droplet an ocean
for a long time and they all talk up
their beans to each other at the end and
what color is that I would never green
item was never in a plant my little
water droplet never made it there you
know it something like that so it's
really cool the way they share it
afterwards which is a really win for me
that they understand it enough to share
with their friend and talk about where
they were in that cycle a little more
prep work because you got to buy the
beads and and the makes a little rice
but but it is a fun water cycle game
awesome are there any other
questions about babies general Gardens
based learning theory or about the
internship or anything else that we can
help you out with today
you
you
thank you yeah thank you everyone for
attending thank you to Roger and Meg for
their awesome presentations and I just
do want to stick in a quick plug for a
webinar that Cornell Gardens based
learning will be hosting on September
7th we have some really exciting
upcoming projects the following year we
like to sort of give you a teaser about
them and give you some more information
about how you can be involved so please
get that on your calendar September 7th
I believe it is time to raise your 10:30
in the morning and we're looking forward
to seeing you all there so if you have
any other questions feel free to ask
them but it's not thanks to everybody
and have a wonderful day thank you
everybody thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu